[Música]
este lunes el gobierno de Colombia y la
guerrilla del elnr toman las
conversaciones de paz en Venezuela un
proceso enmarcado en la promesa de paz
total del presidente colombiano Gustavo
Petro y lo más que anunció que va a
devolver la cuenta de Twitter a Donald
Trump el ex presidente fue suspendido de
la red social tras el asalto al
Capitolio y sus acusaciones infundadas
de fraude electoral en las
presidenciales de 2020
Karim Benzema no jugará el mundial de
fútbol de Qatar 2022 el actual balón de
oro se lesionó durante el entrenamiento
de este sábado con la selección francesa
y en la víspera del inicio de las
competiciones llegó a acatar la
Selección de Brasil
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano
este lunes empiezan en Caracas la
capital de Venezuela las negociaciones
de paz entre el gobierno de Colombia y
la guerrilla del lln un proceso
enmarcado en la promesa de paz total del
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
nuestra corresponsal en Venezuela
Daniela Zambrano nos amplia
lo que se conoce hasta el momento Es que
la reunión será en horas de la tarde en
Caracas el próximo lunes 21 de noviembre
y que fue públicamente convocada la
prensa nacional e internacional a dar
cobertura lo que sería formalmente el
reinicio de los diálogos de paz entre la
guerrilla del Ln y el gobierno
colombiano la información fue difundida
por la oficina del alto comisionado para
la paz Danilo rueda como parte de este
proceso la fiscalía colombiana anunció
que se levantaron las órdenes de captura
contra 17 miembros de la guerrilla del
Ln una información que fue remitida a
Interpol en esta oportunidad se
incorporan al equipo negociador del
gobierno colombiano el actual presidente
de la federación colombiana de ganaderos
una decisión que sorprendió Pues se
trata de una persona bastante crítica a
la administración de Gustavo Petro
también se incorporaría OTI Patiño un
antiguo militante del grupo guerrillero
m-19 Grupo al que recordemos también
perteneció el actual presidente de
Colombia Venezuela
y Nicaragua son los países grandes de
este proceso que recordemos inició en
2017 bajo la administración del
presidente Juan Manuel Santos y que fue
suspendida de un año después por el
presidente Iván Duque luego un atentado
terrorista cometido por el Ln en Bogotá
y el presidente electo de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se reunió en
Lisboa Portugal con la comunidad
brasileña del país europeo después de
verse el viernes con el presidente de
Portugal Marcelo revelo de Sousa y con
el Primer Ministro Antonio Costa frente
a la comunidad brasileña residente en el
en la expotencia colonial Lula apeló a
derrotar sin violencia al radicalismo
del bolsonarismo además el mandatario
reiteró su compromiso con la educación y
con la lucha contra el hambre en Brasil
en las elecciones presidenciales el
líder del partido de los trabajadores
ganó el voto a distancia en los tres
consulados portugueses Lisboa oporto y
faro
y el presidente de Cuba Miguel Díaz
canel llegó a Rusia en el marco de una
gira internacional que comenzó en
Argelia y que lo llevará también a
Turquía y a China en
Moscú canal se reunirá la semana
entrante con el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin el gobierno de La Habana declaró
su interés por importar fertilizantes
trigo e hidrocarburos desde Rusia de
hecho Cuba necesita los hidrocarburos
para restaurar sus centrales térmicas y
acabar con los apagones en la isla
y el nuevo propietario de Twitter el
multimillonario y lo más anunció que
restablecerá la cuenta de Donald Trump
el ex presidente estadounidense fue
suspendido de la red social tras el
asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 y tras sus denuncias infundadas de
fraude en las elecciones de 2020
recordemos que este martes pasado Trump
hizo pública su intención de presentarse
a las elecciones presidenciales de 2024
me gusta ya sabes es un personaje y
suelen gustarme los personajes pero es
inteligente
hizo una encuesta y escuché que es muy
abrumadora pero tengo algo llamado Truth
social
Pero es realmente fantástico y true
social está por las nubes le está yendo
fenomenalmente bien y continuamos en
Estados Unidos porque Elizabeth Holmes
la empresaria de silicon Valley ca por
desgracia fue condenada a 11 años de
prisión por fraude ceranos la empresa
que fundó se había valorado en casi
10.000 millones de dólares al
promocionar una técnica de análisis de
sangre Revolucionaria que resultó ser un
fraude a malven Hoffman nos amplía
Elizabeth Holmes ex estrella de silicon
Valley recibió su sentencia casi 20 años
después de fundar terranos una startup
que prometía una Revolución en los
diagnósticos de salud la ex ejecutiva de
38 años Fue condenada a 11 años de
prisión por un juez Federal de distrito
se trata de un caso de fraude en el que
un proyecto impresionante salió adelante
con grandes expectativas solo para verse
luego frustrado por falsedades
tergiversaciones arrogancia y mentiras
aunque se ha declarado inocente la
acusada expresó sus arrepentimientos
estoy devastada por mis fallos Durante
los últimos años he sentido todos los
días un profundo dolor por lo que la
gente tu pasar por mis errores
Holmes que dice tener fobia a las agujas
fundóteranos a los 19 años con la idea
de fabricar una herramienta que pudiera
extraer una gota de sangre del pulgar y
dar a los pacientes recuentos sanguíneos
completos de forma casi instantánea en
pocos años consiguió ganarse la
confianza de los principales
inversionistas convertirse en la primera
mujer multimillonaria de silicon Valley
y en una de las pocas directoras en un
mundo predominantemente masculino pero
en 2015 el escándalo estalló cuando el
medio Wall Street journal reveló que la
máquina prometida nunca funcionó
sunnyvaloani el Antiguo compañero de
Holmes y director de operaciones
veteranos fue juzgado por separado y
también declarado culpable de fraude
está previsto que su condena sea
pronunciada el 7 de diciembre y en otras
noticias La estrella del fútbol francés
Karim Benzema no jugará el mundial el
actual balón de oro se lesionó durante
la jornada de entrenamiento de este
sábado de la selección francesa La
actual campeona del mundo durante la
madrugada de Qatar la selección comunicó
la lesión de Benzema en el cuádriceps de
su pierna izquierda como consecuencia el
jugador deberá permanecer fuera del
campo durante tres semanas
por otro lado el cambio de calendario
del mundial para evitar las altas
temperaturas de junio y Julio en Qatar
provoca que muchos equipos estén
Ajustando su llegada al país anfitrión
hasta el límite precisamente este sábado
llegó a acatar la Selección de Brasil
mientras en las favelas de Río de
Janeiro un grupo de jóvenes jugadores de
fútbol entrena para llegar algún día a
vestir la camiseta de su selección y
salir de las favelas
llegar a jugar en un mundial un sueño de
cientos de niños que viven en las
favelas de Río de Janeiro entrenan
incansablemente para ser como sus ídolos
de la selección brasileña Adriano
Ronaldo Romario y vicios Junior salieron
de estas favelas y son Inspiración de
una nueva generación de jugadores que
están entre los 5 y 15 años
Brasil siempre ha tenido estrellas del
fútbol tuvimos a Pelé a Marta en el
fútbol femenino a Ronaldinho a Neymar
en estos barrios pobres el fútbol es más
que un deporte es una forma de movilidad
social los niños y jóvenes lo ven como
una manera de salir de las favelas así
también lo ve Francisco que creó en 2019
el equipo de fútbol ferroviario David en
el complejo Favela alemán un sitio que
figura con frecuencia las noticias por
ser hogar de capos de la droga y
violencia policial
el fútbol para ellos es mucho más de lo
que vemos aquí además de su dignidad y
su sueño utilizamos el fútbol como una
herramienta
una herramienta de trabajo A partir de
aquí pueden ir a la universidad
convertirse en hombres más responsables
Y eso viene de usar el fútbol como
herramienta
y también su sueño Todos quieren jugar
un mundial
en 2014 en la cercana Favela mineira
estuvo el Astro del fútbol Pelé donde se
hizo fotografías e inauguró un nuevo
campo muchos de los niños de hoy no
alcanzaron a conocerlo pero oyen
ávidamente todas las anécdotas sobre su
visita Ahora solo esperan algún día
vestir la camiseta amarilla de la
selección y son unánimes en sus
predicciones dicen que Brasil llegará a
la final será el campeón de la copa y
llevará un sexto título a casa y los
dejamos con estas imágenes de la edición
54 del Sao Paulo Fashion week el evento
cumbre de la moda en América Latina que
se celebra del 16 al 20 de noviembre
quiere hacer reflexionar al público
sobre el desperdicio de textiles el
consumismo y el impacto ambiental de la
industria de la moda y en esta ocasión
como en ediciones anteriores también
desfilan modelos trans de grandes tallas
indígenas
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en francés 24 y 24.com
[Música]